camera movement does not automatically
make a shot better it can make a shot
worse
how do you decide when to move the
camera well again i primarily defer to
the director
um but but i'm not one of those people
who likes gratuitous movement i've
worked on shows there are certain
styles of filmmaking or gratuitous
movement and she's like always keep the
camera moving i i like it to be
motivated i like there to be a reason
for it to be moving
um
and and i just intuitively it's like
when i'm in that space i'll feel that
moment where i'm like you know we really
should go from here and then slide over
to that person or you know just how cool
we got to follow them in through this
door and outside
um
i would probably like to move the camera
a little more than i do
but when you move the camera it can
complicate lighting because you have to
hide
stands you're seeing more of the space
um
you have to have a you know
and i
if i was given a choice between moving a
camera or doing cool lighting i would i
would probably do the cool lighting
i know people who do
less than cool lighting to permit more
camera movement and
you know that
again that's a legitimate aesthetic but
it's not my preferred aesthetic
um
but but in a perfect world you could
have both um um and again like i said i
just uh unmotivated movement
it's a distraction i just i think even
with lighting i mean you could do cool
lighting that doesn't complement a scene
you know and and uh it should never be
about making yourself look good it
should be about complimenting the actors
and complimenting the story you know
telling telling that story in a way that
the the people lose themselves and it um
you know one of the things that visual
effects artists often say
is that is that our best work is the
work that nobody notices
and i feel that that's that's kind of
true for me i mean i always like it of
course when people say well that was
really pretty and beautiful
but but i hope that it's because
it complemented that moment and that
they you know they saw these two people
in love and it was just so beautiful um
and not that it was like
distracting in some kind of way because
that's not
you know that's that doesn't serve the
the the higher purpose that we're all
supposed to be there for
when you shot the video store
one location yeah teens sort of sounds
like the thriller yeah type movie
what were you focusing on movement or
lighting or how are you making it
interesting within that one space
well
you know there was there was a little
bit of all of the above you know the
director rolf kanepski is
you know just
really passionate about coverage he has
lots of different ideas about about
getting
a variety of coverage on scenes
and again we had motion where we needed
to have it
and
some of the things that we did to keep
that movie interesting
um
you know in the beginning of the movie
they're all standing up and they're
talking
and um
so we
kept like the top half of the walls had
colored bands on them and they had
colored neons
and the bottom halfs of the walls were
gray
and
so we came up with a design
where the lighting would evolve and um
in the beginning it's just you know a
very neutral
fluorescent lit thing with these these
neon signs and um then this this
conflict occurs
and at first people it's like all fun
and games and so they turn off the
fluorescent lights and i'm motivated
from those neons i put my own lights
above them and i match those colors and
it's like now it's kind of a nightclub
so i'm like you know they're they're
having fun it's kind of a nightclub feel
um and then then things get more serious
and and those lights go out and there
was a there was there was a dramatic
motivation for that to happen um and
then there's a confrontation where these
spotlights are shining through the
windows and it became almost monochrome
and and the angles there were a lot of
angles like this so you're not seeing
the colored bends anymore you're seeing
the gray you're seeing the ceiling
so all of those things you know it was
like
i remember thinking man if it looks the
same for 90 minutes it's going to be so
boring and and
it's not going to be dramatic and so the
the lighting had to be a partner
with that story and and and create those
those moods
and you know to ralph's credit he
created that justification in the story
and with the characters
and and we had just a hell of a lot of
fun with it it was you know
one of the things i love about
both that movie and california christmas
is the variety of looks
you know
i do like i love the look of of cook
county
but it's mostly this kind of grim
raw
look which is a cool look but
like in california christmas you've got
the breakfast scene and you've got the
barn at night where they're you know
lifting the food and you've got the
party with the red and you've got the
bar with the blue and you've got outside
the bar usually you've got all these
different looks and that's just man
that's so much fun and and and those are
the ones i'm proud of uh and and so it
was the same thing with this movie
tomorrow by midnight as you just have
all these
really different looks and and then also
as a for an audience member it
disconnects them from what came before
because it's like you know okay this is
visually this is a whole new thing you
know we've gone to another place and
and that was important for the story and
it was important to keep the visuals
fresh again so people aren't just going
oh my god it's that wall again
how does camera movement make a shot
better
the first thing that i would say is that
is that
camera movement does not automatically
make a shot better it can make a shot
worse
um
you know that would be like saying
um how does drinking a margarita make
things better you know
sometimes it does
and there are other times that well it
probably wouldn't be the best thing
um so
you know in in terms of um
the ways in which it does make it better
is you know for instance if we if we're
slowly moving into somebody as they're
having a realization and that that
dawning is happening on their their face
and and as they're having the
realization we're pushing in we're
getting close we're getting intimate
we're getting uncomfortably close to
them the audiences you're like you're
carrying them along and you're like oh
my god i'm right in their face and that
emotion is just huge you know that's
awesome you know or or if you're
discovering something you know you're
you're in a steadicam and you're
following them and it's like what is it
you know what and you see them and
they're looking and what do you say oh
my god you know whatever um you know
things like that where you
were you know again you are
the
audience's proxy you know and and and
how is it interesting to them is it
interesting to them to just sit and
watch these people talk blah blah blah
blah you know or or do we feel we want
to take that audience and let's get them
in closer you know or let's do a move
where we suddenly don't see this
person's face you know and they're going
to be thinking why don't i see that
person's face you know what what are
they saying what are they doing what are
they looking at
you know
i have this really f
favorite story from rosemary's baby and
um
the cinematographer was talking about
there's a scene where ruth gordon
is
on a phone
sitting on a bed
and and
the camera's at the end of a hall
and the director said okay you know set
the camera up so he you know he got ruth
gordon on the bed and she's perfectly
framed you know within the door and he
sets up the cameras this great shot and
the director comes and he says no no no
move the camera we'll move the camera
over and um he says okay he moves the
camera over and the director says no
move it over some more and he moved it
over so far
that all you see is ruth gordon's back
you don't see her face
and this guy's like okay well that's
really weird
so
they finish the movie they go into the
theater the dp's sitting there watching
an audience watch the movie
that scene comes on and the audience
goes
to see around the door
now that's not an example of a move but
that is an example of
what where are you taking the audience
with your camera you know and and and
really that's the when you get them to
that point
you know where they are like
so engaged with this two-dimensional
projection of light
that their
primal instincts kick in
and against common sense they lean to
see around the corner you know again
just like the the idea of the steadicam
where you're leading them you know
through this place it's like you you're
building anticipation what am i gonna
see i'm with that character what's gonna
happen to them what's gonna come out of
over there you know or or you know that
emotional moment where you get right up
into the face
um so
you know again to me to me that's really
what it's all about it's about it's
about
you know with the audience like how are
you
pushing those those primal buttons in
such a way that even a
non-verbal proto-humid would respond to
what have you been the most terrified on
set and what is the scariest shot you've
ever gotten well the most terrified i
ever was on set
um gosh years ago now i um
worked on this mtv show called senseless
acts of video
and
the premise was that they took
scenes in music videos crazy scenes that
were achieved by vfx
and replicated them as stunts
and
had some good time shooting that that
was a fun shoot
but there was this one particular
scene we had this guy named troy he was
our stunt man
and he had what's called a wing suit
and in base jumping that's people who
basically just jump off of buildings and
cliffs and crap with a parachute
so pretty scary stuff and and one of the
things in base jumping is this this wing
suit where
like rocky the squirrel you spread your
arms and these little bits of material
come out and i mean it doesn't you know
it doesn't keep you aloft but it lets
you
kind of rather than going straight down
it lets you get a little bit of soaring
before you deploy your your your your
your uh
parachute
and uh we were shooting in the grand
canyon where he was gonna jump off
and i have a fear of heights and and
part of my fear of heights is because
i'm kind of clumsy
and and i just you know
i don't want to stumble over something
and
go over the edge because i'd be that guy
i'd be the guy in the news that went
over the edge
and um i remember we were shooting in an
area
that was that was um native american
territory
so it didn't have the fences and the
railings i mean it's literally just
there's the edge there's oblivion
and and and some of the guys are like oh
my god let's go look over the edge you
know oh that's awesome 1800 feet down
brad come look come look like hell no
i wouldn't get within six feet of that
edge i figured if i'm gonna fall i'm
gonna have something to land on
so i didn't do it and um
because of the nature of the stunt we
had a lot of cameras and this was these
were like tv sports cameras you know the
ones with the really big lenses the
super long zooms we were shooting it on
video
and and i think i had gosh six eight
cameras plus i had a bunch of cameras
mounted on this there was also a plane
um
and uh
i remember i got there and i and i asked
the crew i wanted to be fair i said
i said i said who's afraid of heights
and nobody said they were afraid of
heights and i said fine
i'm going to be on the camera at the
bottom of the canyon
and you guys are going to be on the ones
around the edge
um
they cabled them in everybody had like a
cable tied off to a stake or something
um
and the cameras were just right there
and i was like oh my god but but i would
take a helicopter
go down which was also interesting
because um in the canyon because the air
is going through the canyon it's very
turbulent so as you go down it's like oh
but even i was okay with that because
you know as long as there's something
between me
and
eternity i'm i'm i'm okay so i even
though that was uncomfortable it was
much better than standing at the edge of
the canyon um
but later on after we rap some of those
guys were like i was just [ __ ]
myself and i'm like you said you weren't
afraid of heights
i was i was being diplomatic because if
they had i mean i don't know what i
would have done drawn straws or
something but but i wouldn't i would
have tried not to make anybody who was
uncomfortable do it but that was that
was to me the scariest moment on set
um
in terms of the scariest shot wow
um
i i don't i don't have one offhand but
i'm
i'm
well i do i do have one actually yeah so
we had uh you know this was 2002
and there were no digital cameras there
were no gopros
and i had an airy 3 which is you know
big 35 millimeter camera and we were
mounting them onto bikes to get these
really hot shots and we had one mounted
on the left rear tire of a bike and and
it was mounted with this rigging called
doggy cam which at the time was new and
it was these thin rails as opposed to
speed rail which is this big you know
big much more rigid stuff
and the the stunt was that the bike was
supposed to drive right at this car
and at the last minute veer off just a
near miss
and um
so we rigged it
now one of the things was we had so many
stunt riders on that
that that we had exhausted
at least as i was told we had exhausted
the experienced people and they had
brought in trick riders people from
vegas who do hot you know hot rod stuff
that's you know not necessarily
precision movie stunts
and i don't know if this person was one
of those i really don't but we did have
some people who were taking chances that
you know the director of the second unit
director who was a professional writer
he was like you know don't do that
that's that's not what you're supposed
to do um but these guys were hot doggers
um but anyone this particular one um
i remember i was sitting
standing on the road and i see in the
distance this car coming and i see him
just getting smaller and smaller
and then all of a sudden there was like
this explosion of black
particles
and he veered and i realized what
happened is he got so close that the
camera impacted the front of the car
blew into a billion pieces
and i'm like my god if that hadn't been
doggy cam if that had been speed rail it
would have twisted him up under the car
and he would have been dead
and i'm just like son of a [ __ ]
and and and and the the line producer
who you know thank god is still a good
friend today but he was so mad
understandably that that camera was
destroyed and he's like brad you
destroyed a camera and i'm like i'm like
i'm like mike i
it was rigged where it was supposed to
be it was rigged appropriately and that
dude just did not
time his move he did not gauge his
distance and i just you know
i hate i hate you know making excuses
but i'm like i had no control at that
point and you know thank god it was
rigged safely so that it fell apart
instead of taking him under the car
so yeah that was probably
one of the scariest because in that
moment i was like my god you know what
happened and is that dude gonna die
how long did it take you to get over to
where that you saw him get smaller and
smaller
i don't even remember i don't even know
if i went over there i probably did but
it's like
that's the only part of it i remember is
like son of a [ __ ] and i and i just
remember that thing blowing into all
those i just i wouldn't have thought a
camera could do that you know it just
shattered